[Musique]
fallait-il qu'il soit vraiment très en
colère ces catholiques intégristes pour
s'en prendre ainsi à une image de
jésus-christ à coups de marteau c'est
pourquoi c'est la barbarie
acquisition une oeuvre de 1987 présentée
à avignon dans le cadre de l'exposition
je crois aux miracles que son auteur
andres serrano avait intitulé piss
christ et
des véritables armes j'étais opposé à
présentation de ce tableau prysmian
dans le ring manière volontaire c'est
peut-être ça pas de ça certains hommes
paraissent harper c'est évidemment en
pleine période de pâques est au coeur de
la cité des papes le choc des cultures
est d'autant plus grand c'est vrai que
les chrétiens sont en général
très souvent attaqués
et personne ne dit rien pas de bol le 7
avril l'évêque d'avignon avait déjà
demandé le retrait de l'oeuvre et le 16
la veille du saccage 800 manifestants se
retrouver pour prier devant la fondation
du galeriste yvon lambert
si on pisse sur ce quelqu'un deuxième
mois le côté cru et bien on veut
exprimer le mépris vis-à-vis de cette
personne est bien de la même manière le
faire sur un crucifix s'est exprimé le
mépris de la croix et je pense que la
liberté de l'artiste s'arrête là où il
porte atteinte aux autres
une question récurrente entre l'art et
la religion on se souvient des
polémiques autour de la dernière
tentation du christ ou d'autres oeuvres
qui s'est quelque peu intensifiées ces
dernières années y'a aucune définition
en droit français du blasphème puisque
le blasphème est une notion religieuse
mais la république elle est neutre en
matière de culte donc elle doit avoir la
même politique à l'égard de toutes les
religions
car si ça avait été un coran ou untel nu
de plongé dans l'uriné là je crois que
jamais cette exposition n'aurait eu lieu
ce qui bien entendu n'excusent pas la
destruction ou la tentative de
destruction de l'homme andres serrano
lui se défend de tout désir de
provocation et se présentent au
contraire comme un bon croyant
moi ce que je crois c'est que ce sont
les gens qui l'ont qui ont agressé son
son oeuvre qui sont de très mauvais
catholique parce qu'en fait l'offre
qu'est ce qu'elle nous raconte elle nous
raconte que la religion catholique c'est
la religion incarner que dieu s'est fait
homme qui s'il s'est fait homme ballom
fait pipi et caca bon et que l'oeuvre de
serrano représente ça c'est vrai qu'à la
fin les années 80 elle a suscité un
scandale aux etats unis parce qu'il y
avait tout un mouvement réactionnaire
très très fort à l'époque
bon aujourd'hui on peut dire c'est
vraiment des courants très très
marginaux qui s'opposent à ce genre
d'art
ils sont pas très représentatif de grand
chose de mon point de vue est la preuve
c'est que quand même il ya une grande
majorité de gens pour protester contre
cet acte de vandalisme
agnès tricoire bernard debré bonsoir
bonsoir
1 nous venons voir un reportage de
céline joly à propos de la polémique
suscitée par la vandalisation dans les
bureaux de la collection d'art
contemporain yvon lambert en avignon de
deux oeuvres de l'artiste américain
andres serrano immersion piss christ et
soeur jeanne myriam des images jugées
blasphématoires pour certains est de
l'ordre de l'expression artistique pour
d'autres voilà une polémique qui l'a
conduit à nous poser la question peut-on
censuré l'art au nom de la religion
j'ai souhaité en parler avec vous vous
agnès tricoire
m vous êtes avocate au barreau de paris
spécialiste en propriété intellectuelle
vous représenter la collection lambert
dans la sphère puisque rise délégué
l'observatoire à la liberté de la
création
vous êtes aussi l'auteur de petit traité
de la liberté de création à la
découverte
justement un traité qui pose la question
les artistes ont-ils tous les droits
alors je vous pose la question qui est
assez similaire
peut-on censure est là au nom de la
religion non non ma réponse est claire
nette et définitive non
voilà qui est ma réponse c'est non aussi
et oui comme vous ai pas encore posé la
question
c'est dommage je perdais de bref cet
ancien ministre de la coopération
vous êtes député ump de paris docteur en
médecine chirurgien des hôpitaux et
professeur à la faculté de médecine
on vous connaît pour vos travaux sur la
bioéthique et vous sortez aujourd'hui en
librairie de l'éthique et du choix de
l'homme chez des clés debrauwere héroux
pose la même question vous avez répondu
au rendez vous allez devoir y répondre
de nouveaux surtout que en ce qui
concerne cette affaire vous avez réagi
sur votre blog
dans un article intitulé pardonnez leur
ils ne savent pas ce qu'ils font et
c'est une citation donc on verra ce
qu'il en est de la propriété
intellectuelle un peu plus tard les
répondez à la question
cette citation n'y a pas de propriété
intellectuelle leur dirais même ma
réponse est double non bien sûr qu'on ne
peut pas s'assurer qu'on ne doit pas
censuré est-ce qu'on peut tout faire
alors là c'est non peut pas censuré dans
son article très polémique et très
virulent est ce que le droit de
manifestation droit de pétition est
interdite en france
ah bon c'est une pétition est ce qu'on
peut impunément comme ça allait faire
des oeuvres qui blessent une religion
je crois qu'on est dans une république
laïque vous savez ce que c'est qu'un
athlète et bien oui mais c'est justement
de permettre à toutes les religions de
s'exprimer sans qu'elles soient humiliés
vilipendés qu'est ce qu'on aurait dit
j'ai vu le corps en avant dans la mer de
sauter sur le commandant la merde
expliquez nous donc ceux qui dans cet
ordre oui ne serait pas de l'art
premièrement ce que vous affirmez dans
cet article
et deuxièmement et c'est vrai que c'est
battoir extermination expliquez moi
d'abord ce que c'est que là parce qu'ici
c'est de mettre un peu ses fidèles
l'esat ont poussé bin je considère mais
est ce que j'ai le droit d'avoir des
jugements de 20
il me concerne mais vous êtes formidable
c'est donc pour la liberté d'expression
est-ce qu'il est tout à fait normal
alors je vais vous donner les autres
oeuvres est ce qu'il est normal que la
religieuse se masturbe c'était le type
buy a marqué triomphe de l'alm la chaire
2000 par le même oeuvre une religion ce
qui se masquent une religieuse qui se
masturbe un artiste est-ce que c'est là
le même artiste la pietà l'avait acheté
un mérou éventé en lieu et place du
christ c'est tout à fait formidable
après le cardinal le cardinal je
détourne d'une femme nue mallié poitrine
flageller je trouve scandaleux de voir
qu'on utilise des symboles de la
religion pour noël on aurait très bien
pu utiliser l'étoile de david la médecin
d'api ce qu'est ce que ça aurait fait
tout le monde aurait crié tout le monde
à hurley on aurait mis les symboles de
la religion musulmane dans la piste
également on aurait trouvé ça scandaleux
il y aurait eu des manifestations parce
que la même curieux que ça se voit que
la religion catholique qu'on ait droit
d'insulter une manifestation bien la
rubrique à une manifestation avignon la
bei qui a nommé qui a selon elle a
débouché sur le vandalisme de l'oeuvre
et alors vous savez que les vandales
s'en sont pris au visage du christ et
que rarement j'ai vu quelque chose
d'aussi violentes y lisons et s'en sont
ils ont cassé le écoutez-moi de seconde
non on m'accusait ces documents mais
chaque parent peut parler aujourd'hui
d'alliance et des ennuis ya quand même
parce que votre position à encourager
les gens à manifester parce que tout le
monde vous ai dit tout le monde vous ai
dis bravo héros c'est formidable et
c'est là parce que la cadre de la
république on appelle à vous avez
parfaitement droit mais vous savez très
bien que vous avez donné un coup de
virages à l'extrême droite avec avec la
reprise de poser chaque camp des chemins
que vous donner raison aux catholiques
intégristes chez les catholiques - simon
matin vous avez de notre étude
intégristes ou un jeune et je vous
disais à mes yeux
le virage à écouter ce que je dis je
vous avez encouragé au vandalisme de
l'oeuvre et les vandales s'en sont pris
en particulier au visage et ça ça vous
gêne vous voulez me reposer de le dire
au visage du crime et à coups de pic à
glace qui sont les profanateurs qu'ils
sont les blasphémateurs c'est serrano
qui fait une oeuvre dans laquelle on le
voit strictement rien de dérangeant ou
ce sont les quatre petits d'un vandale
qui s'en sont pris à kiel up de marque
et à coups de pic à glace aux us et au
visage du christ massacrés et on voit le
mur derrière
qu'est ce qui est le cas des amateurs
alors je vais bien sûr que je prends ce
que je dis pas ce que moi contrairement
à vous monsieur quand je parle d'une
autre je vais la voir
et là en l'occurrence je les ai vus
avant les jo les vieux pots de crème
je n'ai vu avant vous allez je la veux
avant oui oui ça vous on ne dirait là
vous l'avez lu je l'aimais vu dans les
emails titre en quoi les plâtres
abattoirs en belgique on oublie le titre
on oublie regardez l'image vous dit
qu'elle est choquante cette image elle
se lance dans un récit fait d'un tapis
c'est pas choquant mais c'est votre
propre c'est un croyant solal ça se voit
que c'est tant pis on voit une espèce de
2,2 rouge orangé et comment s'appelle
cette oeuvre
elle s'appelle peace prize et c'est pour
ça que je vous dis ceci vaut quoi ce
problème c'est le titre est ce que l'on
pourrait avancer dans le débat voire
face à une situation comme celle là est
ce que vous demandez qu'on légifère
qu'est-ce que rien mais déjà ça quelques
que doit-on faire pour que ça ne se
reproduise pas selon vous comment
va-t-on faire pour apprécier une oeuvre
d'art la presser en tant que
blasphématoire ou non et savoir quelles
sont les conséquences que je ne vais pas
vous
d'intervention législatif la liberté et
la liberté
c'est ce qui se passe on a le droit de
dire qu'on est content on a besoin on a
notre pétitionner est ce qu'on n'a pas
le droit de vandaliser une oeuvre
je suis totalement opposé c'est tout est
ce que l'on doit ou non à supprimer les
subventions publiques à des oeuvres
considérées comme la sema thouars en
l'occurrence je veux dire je crois que
je suis moi je fais à opposer aux
subventions publiques en général pour
l'art le dit simplement je trouve que
sans arrêt fed est dans une époque comme
ça l'idée de mettre des subventions
deuxièmement on peut évidemment marie
josée roy aurait pu peut-être faire un
seul le maire de viry polique de mer les
minions peur ou catholique
j'suis pas trash suis pas pratiquant
vous vous le dire pas pratique et et ben
je trouve qu'elle a pu te faire
attention
semaine sainte cité des papes bon on
aurait pu demander son avis par exemple
est là elle a déjà connu ça l'a vu hein
ça la regarde je ne veux pas parler pour
elle je n'ai pas le droit de parler pour
moi pour vous le fait que cet artiste se
déclare comme un artiste chrétien
catholique et qu'il a voulu par exemple
déjà dit c'est son intention à montrer
le côté humain du christ est ce que vous
disais tricoire s'est de fait d'exprimer
son opinion pouvait encourager des gens
qui considérait qu'on pouvait aller plus
loin dans l'action
non mais c'est la question aux questions
le bien sûr que c'est de la provocation
c'est très bien j'ai pas de l'api saab
annonce ça s'appelle piss christ c'est
pas de la piste la description du
crucifix dans de la piste en europe avec
le pipi enfin c'est curieux
seyman en est encore là en bout c'est ça
le bout la matière la chair c'est sale
écoutez vous on a quand même un certain
nombre de terroristes le philosophe
chrétien magnifique comme ça tout juste
parce qu'ils vous réconcilier avec la
chair est ce qu'il est ce qu'on peut
dire une arête vous êtes deux personnes
très cultivé vous êtes deux personnes
très cultivé ya deux choses je voudrais
m'adresser aux députés est ce que le
député l'homme politique ne sent pas
dans ce type de réaction là quelque
chose qui s'est transformée et
aujourd'hui une sensibilité particulière
je parle de contexte politique
économique religieux qui fait qu'une
réaction comme celle-là est possible
aujourd'hui
elle n'aurait peut-être pas été il ya
quelques années là je à mon avis elle
est toujours été possible elle a
toujours eu lieu
ses réactions ses manifestations jeux
qui sont légitimes et senc et les
manifestations à venir face à sion
d'intégristes est légitime et 100 mais
attendez je hais ce que j'ai parlé
d'intégrisme est-ce que je suis athée
manifestation à l'union parce que vous
avez droit de censurer qui vivent ils
avaient leurs gardes sont sûrs et marqué
intégré au compteur franchement ils sont
réclamées largement et allez va s'écrire
doute elle connaissait ce qui est invité
à la manifestation josée croze de ce
qu'invités pas vous en [ __ ] parce
qu'il ne parlait alors l'époque et ce
que dit le préfet est ce que c'est alors
vous dites que votre avis il n'y a pas
une sensibilité particulière on a
n'assiste pas à une montée de tension
aujourd'hui selon vous pose la question
que nantes allait il ya des tensions
religieuses interreligieuses elle existe
et dans le monde est en forme
les agités là bas je crois que celle
inverse vous êtes en train d'inverser
tout est en train de commander à
l'étoile à l'émigration vous mélangez
tout vous parlez des migrations des
illégaux audience très important un
moment où il ya des immigrés en france
qu'on dise que c'est que la france est
la fille aînée de l'église
enfin vous rendez compte de ce que vous
dites j'ai pas loin de bien mais c'est m
c'est le conflit des civilisations
allons annoncer ce sera la guerre des
religions et des années j'ai le droit de
dire que non mais vous avez le droit de
le dire mais je dois vous dire que vous
avez tort et comment est ce que vous
dites dangereuses
ah bon voilà alors maintenant il est
dangereux de dire qu'on est chrétiens il
est dangereux de laisser griser
oui il est normal qu'on est chrétiens et
d'enjeux dire qu'on a des civils du
judéo chrétienne j'aimerais que la
france qui a révolutionné la voyons
après elle est passée par là avec les
religions ne sont pas critiquable croyez
qu'elles sont absolument exempte de tout
droit de critiquer ce que c'est que le
blasphème c'est la critique du dogme
mais vous croyez vraiment convaincu a le
droit de les critiquer très dangereux
assez à ce stade de notre débâcle
peut-on faire pour apaiser ces tensions
parce que on le veuille ou pas on est en
face de temps sont élus oui mais je dis
simplement que ça a été de provocation
et que finalement seconde thèse de temps
en temps si ces artistes n'avons pas
cherché la provocation et deuxièmement
je suis contre tout vandalisation qui en
a qui l'aiment ils l'aiment
mais laisser ce qu'il n'aime pas
s'exprimer c'est tout voilà donc ce
n'était pas pour qu'on décroche et
sommes vos bons élèves d'accord pour
qu'elle reste pour qu'elles restent
exposés dans cette fondation pour
décrocher sept ans décroche cette et
marqué noir sur blanc
je suis pour qu'on décroche cette
vendange moment de pâques parce que
c'était une idée très accrochée pendant
noël et vous n'avez rien dit mais je
nous c'est très rare mais je vais
trouver le reprendre le mans texte et
dire que c'est pas bien pour nos être
simplement nummi n'y est pas les ce qui
coince moi je suis nue milite à ceux qui
croient qu est-ce que vous pourquoi vous
dites un truc pareil mais parce que
c'est ce qui se passe est ce que par
hasard et douceur venu à l'idée qu'il y
a décrété vous avez lu l'éditorial de
lacroix dutil dit qu'ils étaient fous de
ce qui se passe ce sont des créatures
que je sache
qu'est ce qu'ils disent qu'on peut
résumer les moyens soutien je vais au
lit une phrase à le travail de serrano
qui se présente comme chrétien dit aussi
quelque chose de notre époque sur la
manière dont les humeurs ce qui sort du
corps ce que vous connaissez très bien
mais aussi du coeur de l'homme peuvent
submergé le religieux
c'est dominique grenier je veux bien
d'autres éditoriaux on peut pas des
chrétiens fâché c'est juste que je
voulais dire ya dix ans j'ai grandi avec
un sachet oui vous êtes même si je
préfère les chrétiens ouvert sur ces
questions là moi je suis très ouvert non
pas tellement vous qui avez absolument
n'importe pied l'on ne vous inquiétez
pas bernard debré a laissé croire chacun
put apprécier ce qu'il en était des
arguments et de et de votre chance et se
faire une idée en ce qui concerne la
suite de de l'exposition à part cette
oeuvre
l'exposition bien évidemment reste
ouverte jusqu'au 8 mai jusque là et on
va conseiller vos ouvrages est ce que
les artistes ont tous les droits la
question est posée dans votre livre
agnès tricoire petit traité de la
liberté de création c'est à la
découverte
bernard debré de l'éthique ou du choix
de l'homme des paroles et des hommes
sécher des plaies debrauwere écouter jeu
vous remercie pour ce débat on va dire
enrichir enrichi voilà je cherchais le
terme verser 2,6 g l
[Musique]